[Music]
a flick of the kettle
another rummage in the fridge it's all
too tempting when working from home
for the prime minister maybe but for
rachel who was forced to set up a home
office there's no going back i think i'm
more productive at home and i think i'm
i'm pretty sure my boss would agree as
well i don't see the need for it um i
don't know why anyone i could see the
camaraderie of maybe in office work but
in terms of productivity and getting
things done and being able to fit in a
better home life balance i much prefer
to be here
but boris johnson says working from home
doesn't work and has issued a renewed
call for a return to the office
it may have been crucial over the last
couple of years but now the prime
minister believes full workplaces will
improve productivity and revive town and
city centres places like burnley however
are already thriving through remote
working schemes
in fact data published this week
suggests it's the second best area in
the uk to recruit for work from home
jobs a mammoth increase of 391 percent
since march 2020. it means not many
employees need to come to the plus 24
office instead owner dave has managed a
hybrid working plan which works for him
and the company realistically it comes
down to culture and if you've got a
really strong and positive culture in
the organisation that you work within
then your team working wherever they are
they'll work hard they'll work
consistently and they won't find
themselves going off to the fridge to
eat more cheese so is working from home
all that bad is it as the pm thinks
limiting productivity and damaging local
economies there are now more
opportunities for people to stay local
and work remotely or on a hybrid basis
and that's really helping to drive the
rejuvenation of many rural and suburban
areas particularly those which were
previously commuter towns and didn't see
many high street visitors during the day
inside number 10 cheese and coffee may
be a distraction for the pm who's now
made it a personal battle to get
britain's back to the office but it's
clear remote working is ingrained within
many businesses and is proving its worth
in zaman rashid sky news burnley